so when can we expect you back about
that so people need a king no they
already have one that's funny
what will you do I'm not sure for the
first time in a thousand years I have no
path I do have a ride though hey
everyone it's Charlie this is gonna be
my new Thor for video got a lot of
requests to do a video because
everyone's reporting that Gore the god
butcher is supposed to be the main
villain so I'll explain what that means
and how they're laying Easter eggs for a
really big symbiote Venom's story way
down the road after Avengers Secret Wars
remember when we saw the Infinity
Gauntlet in Odin's vault way back during
Marvel phase 1 then they turned that
little Easter egg into a huge storyline
with the Infinity Gauntlet saga in the
movies way way later on so Marvel does
things like that like lays little Easter
Egg something really cool that they then
pay off in a much bigger way way down
the road so we'll break it all down
there's a new round of the Avengers
endgame and spider-man far from home
blu-ray giveaway is all you have to do
to enter that is be a subscriber and
leave your best Thor for theory on the
video so top-10 style number 10 who is
Gore the god butcher most of you
probably at least a little familiar with
the character from the comics but he's
just a member of a lesser race of aliens
living on a backwater nameless planet
that no one cared about his race wasn't
particularly advanced they were very
religious they would worship gods but
Gore growing up not believing in the
gods because they live such a terrible
existence was like there's no way that
gods exist because otherwise they'd be
helping us one day he sees two gods
locked in battle fall from the sky a
golden God fighting another Dark One
that becomes the proof that the gods
exist oh wow there are actually gods but
then he gets really pissed off because
he realizes that there have been gods
this whole time and they haven't been
answering their prayers the gods don't
care about us so number nine
why is Gore such a hardcore threat why
would he demand that there be multiple
Thor's in a movie mostly because he
wields the necro sword one of the most
powerful web
in the universe and actually some recent
retcons have made it way more powerful
than it was originally
during the Thor run when it debuted so
you have a couple of Jason Aaron comic
book runs so Taika Waititi said that
obviously he was doing the female Thor
storyline which was Jason Aaron's more
recent run on the Thor comics but before
that he did the run with Gore the god
butcher that's adjacent Aaron's story
what a coincidence then then TECA whitey
D would mix some of those storylines
together all the Thor versus Gore the
god butcher stuff happened right before
they did Jane Foster female Thor
but when Gore stumbles across these two
aliens the golden God calls for his help
but because he's so pissed off the gods
don't care about us he takes the dark
gods weapon and uses it to finish off
the golden God and this is him off on
his quest but when he picked the weapon
up he found out that it was alive it's
the necro source so it forms this shell
of armor around him it allows him to
reshape the material into weapons a
sword mostly which is why it's called
the necro sword so that is your really
important Infinity Gauntlet style
Easter Egg that becomes much much bigger
later in the comics so remember that the
necro sword is alive and has symbiote
like properties number eight what does
Gore's mission and why is he such a
terrible threat that it would require
multiple Thor's so he wants to kill all
gods in the Marvel Universe not just
Thor in the Asgardian Pantheon every
being in the universe that could be
called to God or receives worship
remember how Thanos said that he
balanced the universe before he got the
Infinity stones and the Infinity
Gauntlet in those flashbacks during
Infinity Ward he just flies his Armada
around the universe going planet by
planet erasing half of all life but
there are hundreds of billions of
inhabited planets in the universe
there's way too many for him to get them
all until he gets the Infinity stones in
the Infinity Gauntlet he can accomplish
his goals with a snap of his fingers
so Gore getting the necro sword makes
him powerful enough to kill gods he's
able to amass an army that he calls the
black berserkers which you know
interestingly enough looks just like the
outriders basically massive space war
dogs but he still has to go around
old-fashioned style to one pantheon at a
time and there are thousands of gods in
the Marvel Universe so he doesn't care
how powerful they are or how long it's
going to take until he learns about the
existence of the
God bomb so 7 what is the god bomb one
of the Pantheon's he finds is he's going
around killing all these gods has a god
of bombs on it like Thor's the god of
thunder there's a God who is God of
bombs out there somewhere so he forces
that God to create a bomb capable of
destroying all God's in the universe
instantaneously but because the actual
bomb winds up being the size of a planet
it takes hundreds in hundreds of years
to build gore has to enslave all these
gods he captures and forces them to
build it this will start seeming
familiar too it's also a bit of a time
travel story because he finds a pantheon
of Time gods and uses their power to
travel through time about 900 years into
the future when the construction of the
bomb is almost finished when he does
that he winds up pulling present-day
Thor along with him who's trying to stop
him and later just a sort of spite Thor
takes a much younger version of Thor
really early in his career pulls him at
a time to show him what the future holds
for him like look at what's going to
happen to you
but because they're all nine hundred
years in the future there's also a third
older version of Thor who since become
all-father he's lost his eye he's lost
one of his arms and replaced it with the
arm of the destroyer so you have three
versions of Thor teaming up in the
future to try and stop Cora the god
butcher talking more about female
versions of Thor you also meet Thor's
granddaughters in that future timeline -
he has three granddaughters all who have
different aspects of his personality
their existence also raises a lot of
interesting questions about who Thor
eventually gets married to in the future
they never fully answer that question
but number 6 Gore is a threat that would
require more than one Thor to defeat
like in the comics it took three
versions of Thor teaming up he's also a
threat that Thor could learn about when
he's traveling around with the as
guardians of the galaxy as of the end of
Avengers endgame I know the guardians of
the galaxy vol 3 isn't gonna happen till
Marvel phase 5 so there might be a
little bit of a time jump on that movie
picks up but a lot of you have realized
that in order for Jane Foster to become
Thor she has to wield a version of
Mjolnir in Mjolnir has been destroyed in
present-day
Thor is still worthy as of the end of
Avengers endgame so they have to find
some alternate version of the hammer in
the most easy logical way to accomplish
that would be for tesseract Loki from
Avengers
game whoo now in present day exists in
that alternate reality to flee his
reality into ours trying to escape a
version of Gore in his universe like
saying that Gore the god butcher in his
alternate reality was successful in
killing all the gods of that universe
and now he's following Loki into our
universe and doing it again that way you
can say that alternate universe Mjolnir
is also able to pass through into our
reality in Jane foster can just wheel
that one
while our Thor still has Stormbreaker
the MCU is writing so hard on multiverse
stories in Marvel phase 4 and Thor 4 is
happening after Doctor Strange in the
multiverse of madness and the Loki TV
series with that other Loki so using the
multi verses of story device to bring
all these plot devices together just
seems like a no-brainer number 5 I know
you're asking about beta ray bill
there's a rumor that they're gonna use
him in the movie which Hammer would he
wield because it's kind of the whole
idea of the character is that he
eventually also gets kind of the powers
of Thor but not quite his hammer in the
comics is called storm breaker but our
Thor is still wielding that right now in
the MCU so remember in the comics how
there are three versions of Thor that
team up to defeat Gore the god butcher
you could use beta ray bill is that
third character that helps team up with
them if you're not gonna use Valkyrie
for that based on what Taika Waititi has
said about the story she'll continue to
be queen of Asgard after the events of
Thor for going into Marvel phase 5 phase
6 and beyond so if they're not gonna
kill off Chris Hemsworth Thor at the end
of Thor for going into Marvel phase 5
they can just have him reforge a new
hammer that he uses and just give beta
ray bill Stormbreaker at the end of the
movie because there's no worthiness
enchantment to wield Stormbreaker you
just need to be physically strong enough
that's why Thanos is able to grab and
pick up Stormbreaker
during Avengers end game number 4 here's
what we get to the venom and carnage
long-term Easter eggs a lot of you
probably realized this anytime you talk
about Gore the god butchered now the
necro sword you have to think about
venom and carnage if you've been reading
comics for the last two years you saw
that Donnie K's who's been writing venom
and now absolute carnage Rick Hawn a
very minor detail from that gore the god
butcher Thor story turning a really
small cool thing into a much much bigger
universe crossover event what he did was
is
the necro sword the Gor wielded was
actually a symbiote because it had
symbiote like properties so it was a
pretty easy jump to make but not just
any symbiote the primal symbiote the
most powerful one the very first
symbiote created by a dark God called
null who predates the creation of the
universe he existed in the void before
the Big Bang and then crossed over after
the Big Bang and started going around
trying to kill all the Celestials to try
and basically end our universe and take
everything back to the darkness from
which he came right now they're using
that necro sword story as the basis for
absolute carnage saying that the carnage
character is wielding it trying to bring
back this ancient god and right now Sony
is so thirsty for that MCU Marvel money
that they would jump at the opportunity
down the road to further legitimize the
venom and carnage characters by doing an
even bigger crossover with their
universes and the Spider Man characters
that they control so three right now
there is no symbiote of any kind in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe that we know
about venom is just a Sony character
they've sort of done an alternate
storyline they kind of explained the
origin of the symbiote stirring that
movie but they haven't really really
gotten into it yet
that's where Avengers secret Wars comes
in because we have all the Fox Marvel
characters it's a lot easier for them to
do a comic book accurate Avengers Secret
Wars movie in six or seven years or
whenever they want to get to it down the
road and just like in the comics use
that event to give spider-man the
symbiote so just like Odin's vault
Infinity Gauntlet and then infinity saga
storyline they can turn the Thor for
Gore the god butcher necro sword Easter
egg into a much bigger no venom carnage
crossover event after Secret Wars one
thing at a time though that's all really
complicated stuff
number two we already know from the
Russos that Marvel has long-term plans
for an Avengers Secret Wars movie but
it's gonna be a long time before they
actually get there that storyline is so
meta so even if they break that up into
a couple different movies because
there's so much stuff going on we all
know that they're doing it at some point
number one big question though is what's
going to happen to Chris Hemsworth's
Thor after Thor for the whole idea of
the gore the god butcher storyline and
then the female Jane Foster Thor
storyline is the
main version of the our Thor learning
the true meaning of what it is to be a
God in the universe and obviously
talking about the movie is the Marvel
Cinematic Universe you bring his arc
full circle and if they don't kill him
off he'd probably just spends the rest
of his time quote-unquote answering the
prayers of people all over the universe
wall of the Jane Foster Thor stays
relatively local to earth and just
cameos every once in a while other
people's movies so everybody let me know
in the comments if they're gonna do Gord
the God butcher let me know if you want
them to lay some Easter eggs for
possible venom absolute carnage stuff
way way down the road with the necro
sword I'm still working on eternals and
other Marvel phase 4 videos but leave
your requests in the comments below and
I'll name a giveaway winner when I post
a new Marvel video everybody click here
to learn about that Red Hulk Avengers
endgame deleted scene and click here for
my video on Dark Avengers in the secret
Marvel phase 5 movie list that we've
just found out about thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight
[Music]